bonjour manuel bonp merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique député des
bougeron coordinateur de la France
insoumise on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Julien l'cuiller de la
voie du Nord bonjour Julien bonjourian
bonjour Manu BP bonjour manuel bonpard
vous avez suivi j'imagine avec beaucoup
d'ATT tion les premiers pas de Gabriel
hatal il était dans le Pas de Calais à
la rencontre des sinistrés des
inondations hier il était dans un
commissariat dans le valdoise au côté de
Gérald armanin comment vous jugez les
premiers pas du nouveau Premier ministre
bon qu'il aille devant devant des des
des personnes sinistrées dans le pcalis
ça me paraît être effectivement sa sa sa
mission il y a des gens qui sont dans
une situation de de grande souffrance et
il est normal que l'État se tiennent à
leur côté de mon point de vue il y a pas
énormément de surprise sur ce sur ce
sujet pour le reste moi j'attends
maintenant de voir sur commissariat hier
sa rencontre avec les polici de faire de
la sécurité un objectif prioritaire
signale quel signal ça offre puisqu'il a
parlé de de faire de la sécurité de
l'ordre absolu ce que doit comprendre je
crois monsieur hatal c'est qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir d'ordre sans justice et que
moi ce que j'attends de la part du
gouvernement de manière générale c'est
de nous dire qu'est-ce qu'il compte
effectivement faire pour faire en sorte
que les difficultés en particulier
social auxquel sont confrontés les
Français depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois quelle réponse il compte y apporter
on est aujourd'hui face à des prix qui
contrairement à ce que nous dit le
monsieur le maire depuis maintenant 2
ans continue à augmenter en particulier
des prix de l'alimentation il y a
l'annonce d'une augmentation du prix de
l'électricité de 10 % au 1er février il
y a déjà eu 26 % d'augmentation en 2023
par exemple si Monsieur hatal voulait
donner un signal qu'il tient compte des
préoccupations des Français des Français
il pourrait dire on va annuler cette
augmentation de l'électricité de 10 % au
1er février voulez dire qu'il se trompe
de priorité c'est que il fallait pas
parler de la sécurité mais la bien sûr
que les gens veulent vivre en sécurité
mais je crois que ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que la sécurité elle
recouvre un certain nombre d'aspects et
que quand on veut vivre en sécurité on
veut vivre par exemple en sécurité
sociale on veut pouvoir manger à sa fin
on veut pouvoir se chauffer ça aussi
c'est de la sécurité donc je pense qu'il
a une visandz en première mesure le
rétablissement d'un d'un bouclier sur
les tarifs de l'électric je lui je je
lui demande malheureusement j'ai entendu
que monsieur hatal a l'intention
d'inscrire sa politique dans les pas de
Madame borne et de Monsieur Macron donc
je veux pas donner l'impression que j'y
crois beaucoup mais je pense que sil
voulait tenir compte des préoccupations
premières des Françaises et des Français
souvent vous parlez des sondages bah que
disent les sondages ils disent que les
premières préoccupations des Français
aujourd'hui c'est la question du pouvoir
d'achat et c'est la question de la santé
donc si Monsieur hatal voulait vraiment
être à la hauteur de ses préoccupations
je pense effectivement qu'il serait
temps de bloquer les prix pr sur
l'alimentation à la baisse d'annuler
cette augmentation du prix de
l'électricité peut-être avez-vous
entendu hier que cette augmentation de
10 % du prix de l'électricité au 1er
février et uniquement dû à une décision
gouvernementale le prix de l'électricité
sur les marchés a baissé il y a la
possibilité d'annuler cette haosse il
suffit d'une simple décision
gouvernementale par exemple il pourrait
effectivement décider de le faire voilà
là je crois que en faisant ça il
enverraer des messages vis-à-vis des
franç vous cez un changement de de cap
non non je vous dis qu'est-ce que de mon
point de vue il devrait faire mais je
suis pas naïf j'ai entendu et j'ai suivi
avec attention ses premières
déclarations j'ai écouté ce qu'a dit le
président de la République lors de ses
vœux présidentiels et j'ai bien
l'impression et je et je je je je crois
pouvoir dire que à ce stade il n'y a pas
de changement de cap à l'horizon mais
normal mais dans ces premières
décladration il s'est beaucoup adressé à
la France qui travaille aux classes
moyenne à ces Français qui doutent mais
qui ont de l'espoir oui c'est adressé
oui c'est tout mais non mais enfin je
veux dire euh ça va pas dans le bon sens
est-ce que le travail c'est pas le
problème c'est pas est-ce que ça va dans
le bon sens ou pas le problème c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a dit ça qu'est-ce
qu'on fait euh or est-ce que aujourd'hui
euh le travail paye suffisamment dans ce
pays clairement non donc si Monsieur
Atal considère que les gens qui
travaillent sont pas suffisamment
valorisés plutôt que d'aller comme en
fait il le dit quand il dit ça
c'est-à-dire essaie d'aller s'en prendre
à des gens qui sont au chômage au ça
qu'est-ce qu'il fait pour faire en sorte
que les gens qui travaillent
effectivement aient des rémunérations
qui leur permettent de vivre dignement
donc qu'est-ce qu'il proposeent en terme
d'augmentation de salaire est-ce qu'il
propose d'augmenter le SMIC de donner un
coup de pouce supplémentaire est-ce
qu'il propose d'indexer les salaires sur
l'inflation comme nous avons proposer ça
ça risque peut-être d'arriver dans les
prochains jours ces signaux là puisque
en l'occurrence il est encore en train
de de bon alors moi voilà ce que
j'attends puisque la question que vous
me posez je pense que comme dans toute
démocratie normale monsieur hatal
devrait dire quelle est sa feuille de
route précisément devrait venir devant
l'Assemblée nationale prononcer un
discours de politique générale mais ce
qu'il va faire le Parlement n'a pas
repris ses travaux et demande et
demander ça je sais pas si c'est ce
qu'il va
faireand j'imagine bah et c'est
normalement comme ça que ça pardon mais
ça fonctionne comme ça dans toute
démocratie parlementaire dans le monde
il y a qu' France où le Premier ministre
serait choisi en quelque sorte et
recevrait l'onction du président de la
République du président absolu la 5e
République qui veut ça et ce n'est pas
la première fois si ça se confirme que
le le le Premier ministre ne demande pas
le vote de confiance du du du Parlement
c'est déjà arrivé par le passé c'est
déjà arrivé mais c'est pas la 5e
République qui veut ça la 5e République
l'article 4 de la constition ne l'oblige
pas mais permet de le faire vous en êtes
d'accord j'en suis conscient d'ailleurs
madame elle-même ne l'avait pas
fait comme Michel R qui était dans la
même position de majorité rel mais c'est
pas parce que certains n'ont pas eu une
pratique que je considère conforme avec
ce qui devrait être les usages de la
démocratie parlementaire que ça donne le
droit à monsieural de continuer vous
pensez qu'il peut le perdre ce vote de
confiance vous espérez qu'il puisse le
perdre non mais moi c'est pas mon sujet
n'est pas d'espérer qu'il puisse le
perdre ou pas c'est que si on veut faire
en sorte qu'il y ait vraiment une
rupture avec ce qui a été fait par
Madame born depuis un an et demi
c'est-à-dire la pratique des 493 à
répétition il faut donc que monsieur
hatal vienne devant l'Assemblée
nationale et qu'il a un vote qui
permette de dire qui est dans la
majorité et qui est dans l'opposition
quel est votre intérêt à ce vote vous
bah je pense que ça éclaircirait les
choses et ça éviterait qu'on se retrouve
comme dans la situation dans laquelle on
est depuis maintenant un an et demi
c'est-à-dire que les budgets passent à
coûp de 493 que les les les
parlementaires sont tout simplement des
saisi du travail qui est le leur qu'ils
ne peuvent même plus amender un budget
que vous vous retrouvez dans des
situations où dès qu'il y a une loi sur
lequelle la majorité n'est pas une
évidence qu'est-ce que ça changé juste
manuel bonpard parce que par exemple là
on entend les républicains dire qu'ils
attendent de juger Gabriel Atal sur les
actes on imagine VO on imagine qu'il ne
voteront pas la défiance ça les
empêchera pas de voter contre le budget
mais ça changerait mais mais mais si
parce que quand il y a un vote de
confiance ça dit qui est dans la
majorité et qui est dans l'opposition
moi enfin ce qui m'intéresse c'est
comment le pays avance or vous voyez
bien que ce qu'a fait la situation dans
laquelle on a été avec Madame barn
depuis un an et demi empêche le pays
d'avancer le pays est bloqué en
permanence par le fait qu'il le
gouvernement ne dispose pas de majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale or monsieur
Macron en nommant un premier ministre
devrait ensuite confier comme mission à
ce premier ministre d'aller chercher une
majorité qui lui permet ensuite de
gouverner il y a pas de secret il y a
pas de surprise je je on va pas se
raconter d'histoire je suis un député
d'opposition je resterai un député
d'opposition mais est-ce qu'il est en
capacité sur son programme de pouvoir
conquérir une majorité ça devrait être
de mon point de vue le sujet centr votre
motion de censure elle est d'ors et déjà
rédigée non mais moi je je préfère qu'il
y a un vote de confiance mais à partir
du moment où il y a pas de vote de
confiance il est normal qu'on utilise le
moyen à notre disposition pour faire en
sorte que en quelque sorte vous ne
craiez pas de galvoder C cet outil
puisqueen effet vous avez pris pour
habitude de déposer une motion de
sensire dès lors qu'il y a un 493 sans
qu'elle soit jamais validé est-ce que
finalement vous ne ternissez pas cet
outils non je pense
que c'est la la multiplication et la
succession des 493 qui affaiblit notre
démocratie c'est pas le fait qu'on y
réponde par des motions de censure
écoutez on est par est-ce que vous vous
affblissez pas vous-même avec des
motions vous avez une vingtaine de
motions de censure au aucune n'est
passée est-ce que vous Aiss pas
franchement vous croyez qu'un député qui
se fait couper le sifflet par le 493
devrait rien dire et devrait dire merci
Madame born de nous empêcher de voter
bah non pardonnez-moi moi j'utilise le
moyen qui est à ma disposition à notre
disposition en tant que parlementaire
pour protester pour réagir pour dire on
naccepte pas 4 on dépose une motion de s
par le fait que ce n'est pas voté vous
montrez la division de l'opposition et
l'absence finalement de majorité
alternative mais mais justement je dire
moi je ne prétends pas qu'il y ait une
majorité alternative à l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai jamais prétendu ça
maintenant si vous vous posez la
question de savoir pourquoi les motions
de censure ne sont pas voté posez la
question à ceux qui décident de ne pas
les voter au députés les républicains en
l'occurrence parce que si les députés
républicains les voter alors cette
motion de censure serait adoptée c'est
eux qui doivent se défendre du fait que
ces motions de censure sont pas voter
moi je les vote toutes est-ce est-ce que
sur cell-là sur celle que vous comptez
déposer s'il y a pas de vote de
confiance toute la nup vous rejoindra où
est-ce qu'il y a des division je sais
pas il faut leur poser la question j'ai
entendu vous en avez parlé on imagine
non non j'ai entendu le le le les les
socialistes notamment les députés
socialistes demander aussi un vote de
confiance j'ai j'ai vu un certain nombre
d'entre eux veut pas forcément dire
qu'ils déposeront une motion voilà c'est
à eux de répondre à cette question pour
ma part je n'ai pas la réponse à cette
question à ce stade un dernier mot sur
les les oppositions puisque dans son
lors de sa passation de pouvoir Gabriel
hatal il a promis d'être toujours à
l'écoute des opposition est-ce que vous
qui avez boycotté les dernières
rencontres de Saint-Denis est-ce que
vous irez là si Gabriel Atal vous invite
non mais attendez d'abord moi je n'ai
pas boycotté les toutes les rencontres
de Saint je suis allé oui oui proteste
pas votre question mais je ve rappeler
que je suis allé à la première que j'ai
fait un certain nombre de propositions
qui sont pas très éloignées que celles
que je vous ai faite tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire la question des prix la
question des des salaires la question
des services publics la question de
l'écologie et que rien n'a été fait et
qu'à partir de ce moment-là je veux pas
faire semblant de continuer à participer
à ce qui manifestement n'était qu'une
comédie d'ailleurs cette comédie semble
maintenant s'être terminée pour le reste
j'entends la la la question pour le
reste si monsieur hatal nous dit qu'il
va rencontrer l'ensemble des groupes
politiques à l'Assemblée nationale euh
pour écouter en tenir compte venir
présenter euh sa feuille de route et se
soumettre à un vote de confiance alors
oui j'y participerai sil nous dit je
vais venir discuter avec vous mais à la
fin finalement il y aura pas de vote de
confiance donc je serai même pas obligé
d'en tenir compte mais si vous convtion
d'y participer c'est conditionné à à son
engagement de de faire un vote de cont
personnellement je pense que ce serait
normal que si il a l'intention d'écouter
les groupes parlementaires de
l'opposition c'est pour sans doute
normalement on est dans un
fonctionnement normal en tenir compte et
donc chercher ensuite à obtenir de la
part de certaines d'opposition un vote
de confiance qui qui soit positif donc
si il est sinon sinon c'est c'est c'est
vous direz uniquement à la condition
qu'il s'engage à un vote de conf en tout
cas c'est ma position honnêtement on l'
pas discuté collectivement aujourd'hui
dans le groupe de la France soumise
puisque pour l'instant on a même pas
reçu d'invitation mais là on spécule un
peu mais personnellement je pense que le
vote de confiance devrait être une
condition effectivement on va parler des
des européennes à venir ce sera dans 5
mois maintenant est-ce que Gabriel Atal
et sa nomination c'est la meilleure arme
antirassemblement national pour vous euh
non je crois enfin je crois pas que les
macronistes soi meilleure arme
antirassemblement national hein puisque
entre 2017 date de la première élection
d'Emmanuel Macron et 2022 date de la
2uxème élection d'Emmanuel Macron le
rassemblement national a progressé en
voie et a progressé en score donc
malheureusement je pense que les
macronistes sont disqualifiés pour être
la meilleure arme pour lutter contre le
rassemblement national par contre oui
bien sûr dans les élections européennes
il y a la nécessité de proposer une
alternative et de faire comprendre ou de
de rendre crédible la la possibilité que
pour s'opposer au macronistes on soit
pas obligé d'utiliser le bulletin de
vote du rassemblement national et c'est
la raison pour laquelle moi j'ai défendu
et je continue à défendre l'idée qu'une
liste commune de laanupes devrait être
de mon point de vue une priorité parce
que c'est ce qui permettrait d'avoir une
alternative crédible et ça par exemple
je pense que ser efficace pour faire
baisser que c'est ce serait
irresponsable he c'est ce que vous avez
dit hier sur BFM irresponsable que
laanupes ne soit pas en capacité d'avoir
une liste commune aux élections
européennes donc ça veut dire ce serait
IR ça veut dire que vous estimez que le
le PS ou les autres partenaires de l'ex
nupes font pr d'irresponsabilité s'ils
ne vont pas avec vous aux européennes
écoutez moi je prends les gens au
sérieux et j'ai entendu après le vote de
la loi immigration au mois de décembre
des déclarations de la part des
socialistes des écologistes des
communistes qui disaient c'est un moment
très grave c'est une rupture c'est une
nouvelle étape qui est franchie dans la
jonction entre le macronisme et
l'extrême droite si on pense
effectivement que c'est un moment très
grave et que c'est un moment de rupture
alors alors ça doit amener à un sursaut
ça doit amener à une réaction à la
hauteur de l'importance de ce moment
j'ai est-ce que ça peut tre la nupes oou
est-ce qu'il faut inventer quelque chose
d' mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
inventer
d'autrees l'autre manière de fonctionner
peut-être non mais alors après on peut
discuter de tout mais laanupes a permis
de remporter le premier tour des
élections législatives quand même
laanupes a permis de multiplier par 3 ou
par 4 le nombre de député de gauche à
l'Assemblée nationale laanupes nous a
permis d'être l'opposition principale à
Emmanuel Macron donc si on veut
continuer sur ce chemin il faut bien
repartir du point auquel on était arrêté
et donc c prenez les gens sérieux vous
les entendez les socialistes les
communistescist ça fait des mois qu'ils
vous disent non à une liste commune
jusqu'à quand vous allez continuer à la
demander justement justement parce que
je prends les gens au sérieux je j'ai
bien conscience et j'ai bien compris
qu'il nous disaient non depuis plusieurs
mois mais je j'ai bien compris aussi que
pour tout le monde le vote de la loi
immigration était un moment de bascule
et de rupture et donc si on veut être à
la hauteur de ce moment de bascule et de
rupture alors il faut être en capacité
de dire que des options qui étaient sur
la table avant ce vote finalement elles
peuvent bouger par rapport à ce qui que
visiblement les les les chicaneries
entre la France insoumise et puis le le
PS n'ont pas cessé malgrées ses appels à
l'Union mais il y a pas de chicanerie
écoutez franchement bah écoutez c'est
pas ce que disent les réseaux sociaux
quand quand des tweets ou des se
répondent les uns les autres appele ça
comme vous voulez moi je considère que à
partir du moment où on est à un moment
d'une telle gravité je pense pas qu'on
puisse prendre prétexte de tel ou tel
échange sur les réseaux sociaux pour
empêcher la liste unique dont on a
besoin la question c'est pas de savoir
si ça fait plaisir à un tel à ou une tel
la question c'est de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on propose au pays qu'est-ce qu'on
dit au français qui sont en recherche
d'une alternative je je pense que oui
effectivement je pense que ce serait
assez irresponsable de dire au français
oui c'est vrai bon le vote de la loi
immigration c'est un moment très fort
très important il y a une rupture qui a
été marquée mais bon on va continuer
comme avant parce que vous comprenez il
faut un appel déjà vous aviez lancé un
appel à ce momentlà au moment de la la
loi immigration vos partenaires de la nu
vous avez eu des retours non non j'ai à
part le parti génération qui a répondu
favorablement non les autres partis
n'ont pas répondu je vais pas vous
raconter vous raconter d'histoire donc
je je forme le vœux qu'il réponde en fin
après Olivier fort convcre Olivier fort
a répondu a répondu malgré tout fin
décembre il disait qu'il pouvait
imaginer une union de la gauche mais sur
des bases claires c'était sur ce plateau
même rien ne peut en témoigner mais donc
peut-être faut-il réinventer des B clair
mais qu'est-ce qu'il n'y a de pas clair
dans le programme de l'anupes enfin je
veux dire le problème c'est qu'on est
dans c'est sur la c'est sur la
centralité on a l'impression évidemment
que tout ça se confond aussi avec
l'influence de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur
sur la ligne de de LFI sur sur les
responsables il y a 75 députés insoumis
à l'Assemblée nationale il y en a 151 de
l'anupes c'est pas moi qui l'ai décidé
ce sont les électrices et les électeurs
donc à partir de ce moment-là mais si
vous nêtes pas en tête des élections
européennes est-ce que c'est pas là
aussi votre crainte est-ce que vous
réclamez pas cor cré une liste commune
de peur d'arriver derrière notamment les
socialistes aux élections européennes et
de du coup reposer de nouvelles bases de
la nu madame en 2019 la liste de la
franceç soumise a fait 6,3 % aux
élections présidentielles de 2022
Jean-Luc mélencha a fait 22 % mais là
dans les sondages c'est le parti
socialiste qui est donné de J EUR j'ai
bien noté et d'ailleurs aux élections
européennes de 2019 les écologistes
avaient fait 13 % et Yannick jado a fait
moins de 5 % à l'élection présidentielle
donc pour vous la base de l'ANUP ça
restera la présidentielle les européenes
non c'est pas ça que je suis en train de
vous dire je suis en train de vous dire
mon sujet aux élections européennes
c'est pas la question de la France
insoumise de savoir quelle est la
position que va avoir la France
insoumise franchement ce serait pas à la
hauteur de la situation de dire ça mon
sujet c'est qu'est-ce qu'on dit au
français on voit bien que la la macronie
est dans un moment de désagrégation bon
et que la question qui est posée c'est
qui est l'alternative qui va gouverner
ce pays demain et je refuse de laisser
penser que seul l'extrême droite est en
position de pouvoir prendre le le
pouvoir dans ce pays c'est ma seule
boussole le sujet c'est pas les intérêts
des insoumis d'ailleurs franchement la
question qu'on a posée quand on a
proposé cette liste commune on a même
proposé qu'elle soit conduite par des
écologistes et même qu'on utilise les
rapports de force issus de la dernière
élection européenne pour composer la
liste si ce qui m'intéressait c'était
juste le poids ou le nombre d'élus pour
les insoumis j'aurais pas fait ces
propositions un moment faut être un peu
sincère si on pense qu'il y a une
situation grave si on pense qu'il faut
être en capacité de proposer une
alternative au pays alors c'est ça qui
doit nous guider pas de savoir combien
va y avoir d' socialist l'alternative
elle est pensée par d'autres personnes
on a entendu les déclarations aussi hier
de Dani dalgo maire de Paris qui qui
appelait à une réunion des listes
écologistes et socialiste est-ce que la
la crainte que vous ayez aussi c'est
d'être débarqué de cette union de la
gauche définitivement mais non mais
enfin je dire ça on l'a déjà connu entre
2017 et 2022 c'était tout sauf Mélenchon
tout sauf la franceç soumise et on va
faire une liste commune en dehors de la
francesmise pardonnez-moi mais la France
soumise elle représente des électrices
et des électeurs donc si vous vouleit
être en capacité de gagner je ne crois
pas que le chemin qui consiste à dire on
va se rassembler sans la principale
composante de la gauche soit un chemin
qui nous amène vers la victoire donc
Madame Idalgo elle a déjà essayé je je
feraai pas l'offense de rappeler son
résultat à la dernière élection
présidentielle je pense que tout le
monde a compris que ça fonctionnait pas
donc encore une fois notre boussole ça
doit être le pays ça doit pas être nos
petites affaires politiciennes bon bah
pour le pays je pense qu'on a besoin de
construire un rassemblement on a compris
ce que vous souhaitez non mais juste
est-ce que dans la réalité parce qu'il y
a aussi la réalité l'échéance c'est dans
5 mois est-ce qu'il y aura une liste la
France insoumise mais je vais être très
clair je souhaite et mon option
privilégiée ça reste de faire en sorte
qu'il puisse avoir une liste commune de
l'anupes je dis que si les appareils de
l'anupes continuent à s'entêter dans ce
refus il y aura une liste de
rassemblement qui portera le programme
de l'anupes mais rassemblement avec avec
tous ceux qui veulent venir porter le
programme de par par bah porté par une
tête de list qu'on choisira
collectivement est notre chef de fil
aujourd'hui donc Manon auri peut
effectivement porter cette dynamique de
rassemblement mais je souhaite que dans
cette hypothèse là ce soit une liste qui
aille au-delà des rondes de la France
insoumise et qui regroupe aussi des
personnes engagées dans l'anupes ou pas
d'ailleurs et qui veulent porter avec
nous le Pr oui mais ça vous l'avez déjà
proposé il y a plusieurs semaines qui
vous rejoint aujourd'hui bah laissez-moi
un petit peu de temps il y a une
convention de l'Union Populaire qui va
être organisée au milieu du mois de mars
d'ici à cette convention on va faire le
travail et si d'ici au milieu du mois de
mars on n' pas réussi à faire en sorte
que la liste commune de laanupes soit
possible alors effectivement on lancera
cette liste de l'Union vous aurez de
mois pour faire campagne oui ça ça fait
court hein bon écoutez vous savez la
campagne des élections européennes
d'abord c'est pas parce que on n pas
immédiatement notre tête de liste notre
liste complète qu'on ne peut pas parler
des sujets européens regardez prenons
quelques exemples je vous ai parlé du
prix de l'électricité tout à l'heure bon
il y a en ce moment discussion au
Parlement européen une réforme du marché
européen de l'électricité nous nous nous
opposons au fait qu'on continue avec
avec le marché européen de l'électricité
c'est-àdire que le prix de l'électricité
soit indexé sur le prix du gaz nous
sommes les seuls le seul groupe au
Parlement européen a refusé la poursuite
de cette logique donc ceux qui veulent
par exemple faire en sorte qu'on
maintienne les tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité qu'on sorte avec cette
logique folle de l'indexation du prix de
l'électricité sur le prix du gaz bah ils
devront voter pour les europut la France
pour la franceise Julien on va parler de
la vague de froid qui oui puisque hier
dramatiquement deux personnes sont sont
décédées dans dans la vague de froid qui
nous ouche un SDF dans une cave à
Boulogne une femme en pleine rue à à
Carpentra il y a 3000 enfants qui sont
toujours dans dans la rue dans dans ce
pays lundi le ministre du Logement a
annoncé 120 millions d'euros
supplémentaires une une enveloppe qui
doit correspondre à 10000 l
supplémentaires ce que vous lui dites ce
n'est pas assez pire que ça d'abord
c'est il y a déjà eu deux drames vous
l'avez dit et je pense que si le
gouvernement veut être à la hauteur de
ses responsabilités il doit empêcher
qu'il y ait de nouveau drames et on n
pas on n pas le temps en fait c'est
c'est tout de suite immédiatement mais
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
empêcher ça veut dire qu'il faut un plan
d'urgence pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait plus une seule personne qui dorme
dans la rue comment et c'est 120
millions c'est pas un plan du attendez
comment en ouvrant des nouvelles places
d'hébergement d'urgence ça c'est ce
qu'il a annoncé non il a annoncé un
budget si on en croit les chiffres qui
permet d'ouvrir 10000 places
supplémentaires d'hébergement d'urgence
il y a 330000 personnes qui dorment dans
la rue vous voyez bien que le budget qui
a été débloqué n'est pas à la hauteur de
la situation donc il faut davantage de
place d'hébergement d'urgence il faut
réquisitionner les logements vacants
aujourd'hui je 330000 personnes qui
dorment dans la rue plus de 3 millions
de logements vacan en France pour une
personne qui dorme dans la rue il y a 10
logements qui sont vides la loi permet
la réquisition des logements vacants
dans un moment d'urgence pour faire en
sorte qu'on mette les gens à l'abri
voilà ce que le gouvernement doit le
faire s'il le fait pas je l'accuse et je
considère qu'il sera coupable de non
assistance à personnes en danger les
gens qui dorment dans la rue aujourd'hui
sont en danger quand il fait froid comme
ça vous savez très bien que ça peut
conduire à la mort on a déjà eu deux
drames de cette nature maintenant il est
temps que le gouvernement plutôt que de
nous amuser pendant encore des jours et
des jours avec les la parodie la comédie
du remanement se retrousse les manches
et fasse en sorte que l'ensemble des
Français soit protégé soit mis à l'abri
qu'on n pas encore un drame
supplémentaire enfin ça me paraît être
une évidence qu'on puisse pas accepter
que dans la 6e ou 7e puissance
économique du monde il y a des gens qui
meurent dans la rue à cause du froid les
gens ne meurent pas à cause du froid il
meurt à cause de l'inaction
gouvernementale à protéger les gens qui
sont confrontés au froid il y a 70 ans
laabé piierre appelé hein lui-même
c'était le 1er février
1954 à une insurrection de la bonté
c'est ce que vous proposez aujourd'hui
bah oui enfin écoutez franchement je
sais pas queles que soient nos options
politiques je pense que tout le monde
peut quand même se retrouver dans l'idée
de dire que c'est pas possible de mourir
dans la rue parce qu'il fait froid et
qu'on a pas d'abri et et d'ailleurs je
je je je rappelle quand même que le
président ident de la République
Emmanuel Macron élu en 2017 avait pris
un engagement que plus une seule
personne sous 3 ans n'allait vivre dans
la rue n allit dormir dans la rue vous
avez dit il y a des enfants qui dorment
dans la rue enfin je sais pas je pense
que toute notre humanité à tous elle
devrait nous conduire à dire
indépendamment de nos désaccords et de
nos conflits politiques là il y a une
priorité faisons en sorte qu'on mette
les gens à l'abri pour qu'il y ait pas
encore davantage de gens qui meurent je
pense que ce message là au moins il peut
être entendu une dernière question
Julien sur la immigration on en avait
déjà on en a parlé vous marcherai he
contre cette loi immigration le 14
janvier là ce dimanche et alors qu'il y
a une autre action qui est qui est
prévue le le 21 avec l' 21 et vous vous
avez signé l'appel en effet avec les ex
partenaires de la deupes mais est-ce que
deux mouvements comme ça est-ce que
c'est pas dommage finalement écoutez je
vais vous dire les choses franchement
nous nous avons travaillé les insoumis
notamment par l'intermédiaire de r
trouvé pour essayer de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait qu'une seule date de
manifestation et nous avons essayé de de
discuter avec les personnes et les
organisations les associations les
collectifs qui appellent au 14 14
janvier avec ceux qui appellent au 21
janvier pour faire en sorte que on se
donne un seul rendez-vous on pas réussi
parce que certains sont partis sur la
date du 14 les autres sur la que c'est
toujours gênant pour les anciens
partenaires de de défiler avec vous
ilont
21 je crois pas que ça soit la question
ça soit la position de la François
soumise d'ailleurs la François soumise
appelle à participer et au 14 et au 21
moi personnellement mais c'est parce
qu'il y a des acteurs associatifs
collectifs qui se sont pas manifestement
accord sur sur les deux initiatives donc
voilà c'est comme ça moi je veux pas
ajouter de la division à la division
c'est pourquoi les oumis nous nous avons
pris la décision de participer à ces
deux manifestations à celle du 14 et à
celle du 21 et j'appelle les Françaises
qui nous et les Français qui nous
écoutent à se mobiliser je pense que
tout le monde doit entendre que cette
loi immigration a défiguré l'image de la
France qu'elle a créé de l'moi que elle
elle donne l'impression que la France se
rabougrie se referme sur elle-même que
c'est une rupture avec un certain nombre
de principes républicains desg é entre
par exemple un travailleur français et
un travailleur étranger et et parfois on
a essayé de faire croire aux Français
que cette loi allait ajouter ou
répondre à des difficultés qui
rencontrent mais je veux juste dire
aucun Français ne va gagner du fait
qu'on va rendre la vie des travailleurs
étranger plus difficile et si les
travailleurs étrangers arrêtai de
travailler pendant une journée vous
verrez l'apport qu'ils pour qu'ils ont
pour le pays donc je pense que les
Français doivent se mobiliser merci
manuel bpard merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité la une de la voie du Nord
ce sont les inond cette solidarité qui
fait chaud au
cœur Gest dans cette période difficile
c'est à ce matin dans la voie du Nord
merci Julien la semaine prochaine on
passe au club des territoires